are going live live yes if you guys can
see us we cannot see that we are live
yet but we think we're live we're just
in South Africa and everything but slow
here with the Wi-Fi and everything but
welcome to dlm men's lifestyle first
live video and
we've got a big announcement to make but
before we do that let's wait a few
seconds for some more people to join
let's see who's here
[Music]
yeah me too son of David oh you were
here on dlm Christian lifestyle as well
yes that's awesome thanks for joining us
hey Samuel good morning oh it's evening
here at 7 p.m here in South Africa we
had a long day and uh now we're here
talking to you guys hi Janine hello
another Samuel Nina career for those of
you who do not know that is nikidas
thank you for joining look I'm on TV or
video
yeah
uh if you guys don't know who's this
crazy lady next to me this is my wife
Nikita for those of you who who joined
uh dlm means lifestyle yeah because
people are probably wondering what's the
woman doing here
I'm here because I'm celebrating this
amazing moment with my husband the
publishing of his new book bold Pursuits
all right right right Nikita helped me
and worked so hard for the team as well
here we go bowl Pursuits it is a big day
today it is live everyone
thank you Lord Jesus worked really hard
in this one and we need to pray that God
will change many lives through this book
yeah speaking about the book uh for
those of you that haven't purchased it
yet maybe you can go and have a look of
um all the information of the book is in
the video description below and you can
find it on either our
dlmchristianlifestyle.com website just
go to the shop link and then you'll see
it there or you can go to the book
website directly which is bold
pursuitbook.com and you can buy it at
different retailers you buy it online
and they ship it to you all over the
world I know it's not yet available in
every country
um but definitely in the United States
it's there and Canada yeah but you can
get the ebook on audiobook I've done the
voice over myself
um we did we just did the the video on
Christian lifestyle and we shared a
little bit so some of you know this but
some of the new members here who is live
they don't know this but if you like
jogging if you like driving then then
you can get the audio yearbook
um man this is special this is this is
really special this is the second yeah
the second life the second life ever
That's so exciting I'm not that nervous
anymore because we did the first one
just a few minutes ago so yeah but yeah
listen before we continue also some
exciting news we are having a
competition at the end of this video we
are giving away 18 free copies of bold
Pursuit book so watch till the end of
this video and then we'll give you some
more details yeah but yeah Daniel
what tell us a bit more about the book
give the viewers something exciting uh
what was the inspiration behind it I
just love it when it yeah on the channel
um the inspiration for the book is first
of all God right is the reason why I do
the book The reason I do the videos the
reason I do everything is for God right
my love for him and my love for other
people because of God I don't want
people to understand in front of God and
he looks at them and say go away from me
because I never knew
the day and age we live in today there
are a lot of lukewarm Christians
yep and you know we're so busy with this
world this Rat Race that people do not
take their faith seriously
they don't have a real relationship with
God and so this book is first of all to
bring them to the Cross so that they can
understand what a true reborn Christian
is second
how to really grow spiritually to
understand that there's a lot more than
just getting your ticket to heaven
there's a whole Road of sanctification
where you learn certain things how to
fight through the spirit not through the
flesh you know how to come to the point
of complete surrender
where God shows you who you are your
identity in Christ and you start to
follow him in everything you do and you
understand man there's so much that you
still do not know there are a lot of
people out there who are Christians but
they're still infants in Christ they're
not mature Christians yet and you want
to say something all right all right
no I think it's it's also the the
importance of this book is just because
we live in a day and age where men the
essence of being a man is being brought
down so much
um and and the identity of what a man is
or supposed to be especially a Godly Man
is is being taken away out of the
equation almost yeah he's being attacked
and that is why it's so important to as
a man
boldly pursue god without any fear
without any worrying about what people
around you would say right Daniel yes
because that was actually a question why
the name bald Pursuit that was a
question on the Christian lifestyle
comments you can pursue all the wrong
things to try and get peace and
fulfillment in his life you know but
nothing
can give you that except God there's
nothing out there that is more important
than this this world is so short I
learned that from the death of my two
brothers and I know I talk about it a
lot but that is the reality we have a
date where we will be born and a date
where we will die you cannot run away
from death and so you want to be sure
that you are saved yeah there's nothing
more important than pursuing God but
after you find him there's a whole new
world that opens up a new spiritual
world where you start to see the world
definitely I can talk about this the
whole day but I think we should start
let's give them an overview of this
video today yes so the overview of the
video is just going to be well we've
already kind of discussed the book oh
and yes just one more thing about the
book in the coming few weeks we are
going to be posting quotes special
quotes from Daniel's book so keep a look
out for that on our social media and we
are also also going to share a
discussion guide that you can use with
your Bible study group or even with your
home study when you are with family or
friend brains that is going to be really
really really helpful yeah keep your
eyes out because for Ministries for
churches this is very important and
pastors and everybody can use it so we
will post that and you can also I forgot
about it you can also download the free
chapter on the official boldpersuit
book.com website and then in the rest of
the video we are going to share you with
you guys
um day 52 what is a man's role in the
marriage we're going to answer a few
questions and then we're going to end it
off by giving you the details
of the competition right right at the
end of this video so we'll probably be
yeah around 20 more minutes but but guys
this is an informal video this is just
us wanting to spend time with you and I
want you to understand that I'm just a
normal human being Nikita as well
and we just want to spend time with our
dlm family and we're going to look at
the comments every now and then here to
see what you guys are saying and
especially after we go through day 52. a
man's rule in marriage then we're gonna
look at a few questions but I think we
should start yeah let's pray I'll pray
I'll do a quick prayer father just thank
you so much for helping me to write this
book and I pray father that you would
bless it so that people will be saved
and that they will really pursue you no
matter the cost and I want to ask father
that you will be with us here in this
Bible study
help us to clear out all distractions of
this world and talk to us today
amen amen thank you Daniel all right
day 52 a man's role in marriage yeah so
I'm not gonna share the book here with
you because some of you are going to go
ahead and read it while we're gonna have
a discussion over it so
um we're gonna read it this side and I'm
gonna ask Nikita to read a little bit
here and there as well but let's get to
it day 52 a husband's role in marriage I
always start with a Bible verse so
important the day and age we live in
today because people don't follow sound
Doctrine they don't follow the Bible
they follow what they feel like and you
can't do that you can't live that way so
first of all Ephesians 5 25. husbands oh
for those of you who are not husbands
yet you also need to listen so that when
you are married you don't think oh man
what should I do how should I be a good
husband you should learn how to be a
good husband right now
husbands love your wives just as Christ
also loved the church
that means the way that God loves you
Brothers and Sisters in Christ we are
the church right
so I'll say it I'll read it again
husbands love your wives just as Christ
also loved the church and gave himself
up for her woof
are you ready to give yourself up for
your wife my dad said this to me once
you know when I talked about Nikita and
I'm praying for a wife and he said don't
marry her if you're not willing to give
up your life for her
that was that was what he asked me and
so you need to ask yourself that
question as well and apologies if we're
gonna cough now and then I just got
through a flu Nikita as well it is what
it is but thank you guys for praying um
we ask you guys on on the telegram to
pray for me so thank you I'm a lot
better and Akira sorry about that
halfway there
all right so let's continue God created
marriage
full stop God created marriage
we forget right sometimes we think oh
it's my marriage we're married
God created marriage he understands the
relational math that allows two to
become one without subtracting anything
that's important to understand
he designed us so that we can connect in
an extraordinary way with someone else
and experience amazing love joy and
fulfillment from that connection
I've said in the other video but I want
to say it here for some of you who might
not have seen it you know
marriage can be one of the most amazing
things Nikita and I we've been married
for 13 years and Nikita is a blessing
let me tell you that I could not have
asked for a better wife that supports me
men I'm not going to go into this we're
going to get emotional here but if God
is in the marriage it is a blessing
but if he's not it can be one of the
worst things that you will ever
experience in this life
let's continue maybe you want to read a
little bit
um
let me just read that that lost part
again right yeah and experience amazing
love joy and fulfillment from that
connection
so
when God talks about marriage in his
word we should pay attention
unfortunately there are a lot of people
who aren't paying attention studies show
that over the past 40 years the divorce
rate has more than doubled globally oh
my word that's insane yeah when you have
broken families you have broken
societies
and so marriage is extremely important
we forget how important it is
so it has doubled globally combating
this trend begins with understanding
with understanding the unique roles God
created for husbands and wives within a
marriage husbands and wives
let's look at what God's word says about
the role of a husband Ephesians 5 25 and
then 28 to 30 it's 30 says
husbands love your wives just as Christ
also loved the church and gave himself
up for her
so husbands also ought to love their own
wives as their own bodies their own
wives yeah wow that's that's so strong
he who loves his own wife loves himself
for no one ever hated his own flesh but
nourishes and cherishes it
just as Christ also does the church
because we are part of his body as as
you love your body and and yourself you
should also love your wife you nourish
it which you cherish your wife right
that's how you should look at your wife
I think a lot of husbands today are too
selfish because that's the world we live
in today right you scroll on social
media and it yourself this self that
right self-love self-importance
self-respect but what has got to say
that we have to do deny yourself pick up
your cross and follow me there is no
place for I've said it in this under
video as well but I'll say it here for
people who are selfish in marriage that
marriage won't work
okay
I'll read the section then you then you
read the next
all right the love pole is talking about
is a commitment to actively love your
spouse even when you're not feeling the
romance the heroes of love so I'm I'm
just gonna read this section again
because this is the most important
almost of this whole piece
the love Paul is talking about is a
commitment to actively love your spouse
even when you're not feeling that Roman
Romance
Paul is talking about
Agape Agape Agape Agape that's right
Paul is talking about agape love
the sacrificial love that Christ has for
the church
this love is forgiving it compels us to
work to restore our relationship after
we've been wronged
this section is also very important this
makes and I just want to share something
here because a lot of people just focus
on the era's love right the attraction
but that's not going to carry you
through marriage is hard work and so you
need to love the other person the way
God loves them with unconditional agape
love no matter what they do you look at
your wife you know whence is angry
but you don't you know you don't react
to that through the flesh
you put on that switch you act through
the spirit you love her and you
understand that she's also just a human
she make mistakes here and there just
like you yeah
sometimes we might not like each other
that much
but you I'm just kidding but you have to
love your husband or your wife because
God loves them that is what agape love
means right unconditional yeah
so is that a feeling it's an act of your
will yes
sacrificial love is encouraging
humbling
it inspires us to make our own needs and
ones secondary exactly what you said
a lot of people think man my wife
doesn't do this enough she doesn't she
should do this more I need this I I I
and you don't really realize it and you
throw a pity party for yourself oh she
doesn't love you so she doesn't oh look
at that wife look what she is doing for
her husband yeah you shouldn't do that
you should think all right what does my
wife need from me you are the action and
then she will react to your action
don't don't want to have you shouldn't
want to have the perfect wife you should
need to want to be the perfect husband
and vice versa don't want the perfect
husband try and be the perfect wife
well said next
do you want to continue no you can go to
the next section all right so God demons
there's a cough coming God demands that
we as men treat our wives in an
understanding way sometimes that can be
difficult but you need to realizing that
they are unique and different they don't
think like you they are different you
need to just come to the place where you
accept it
at the beginning of my marriage you know
I thought man why is Nikita so different
in this and this and this well
God made us different it would be so
boring if we were all the same right
we need to treat them gently with love
and patience
and I just want to say here you know my
mom
growing up my mom matrudi she always
said and I'll say this in Afrikaans
because you guys know where we speak
Afrikaans our first language dhoni he
would altered
you always have to treat your wife in a
gentle way and I will never forget that
thank you Mom you're probably listening
but it is so true
we need to treat them gently with love
and patience in the same way God takes
care of us wow
who
did you hear that that's how you should
treat your wife the same way God takes
care of us
is not a bossy way it's a loving way
hmm
that's so powerful it is so important to
him that if we do not obey him in this
our prayers will be hindered one Peter 3
verse seven so if you even for you who
think that you're very religious you go
and you're praying you
and you're you're you do a lot of things
for God but at home your relationship
with your wife is not right you can
leave what you're doing
you go back and you make it right do not
go and sleep when you're still angry
where there's something that's that's
you feel it there's still something
between me and my wife
it's your responsibility to go and make
it right if you want God to listen to
your prayers
such an important verse
in Matthew 19 verse 46 Jesus emphasized
the sacred nature of the marriage
that's all right the marriage
relationship responding to a question
about divorce he said this
have you not read that he who created
them from the beginning made them male
and female
I just want to pause here did you hear
that male and female not a donkey a
unicorn or some other thing you want to
identify as male and male and female
that's the truth you know people say
that I have my true view or if you your
truth no we have different perspectives
of the truth there's only one truth
that's God's truth yep
oh get off lost my place here here we go
um fail uh male and female and said for
this reason a man shall leave his father
and mother and be joined to his wife and
the two shall become one flesh so they
are no longer two but one flesh this is
so important there are husbands out
there
who are allowing his parents interfere
with marriage that shouldn't happen
you walked away from them you have a
marriage now with your wife and with God
they are first
so don't allow other people to interfere
yeah and what I want to add something
also to this because it's not
necessarily always people that from
their own active world that want to
interfere into your relationship it is
sometimes
you yourself that cause that drags
people into your relationship and your
problems right and then that makes them
become you know part of it and and what
I'm actually referring to is for example
as women I know that we are emotional
and when you had a little argument or a
little speck with your husband you just
want to vent about it and you want to
get it off your chest and you want to
cry about it and then what we usually do
the first thing is if you've got a good
relationship with your mom you'll get on
the phone you'll call your mom or your
call you will call your friends and just
you know vent and get it out and ramble
on about what just happened and that is
the worst thing that you can actually do
I know that we need to get things off
our chest but ladies the best thing that
you could ever do is to go to the Bible
and work with the Lord through the
problem and the thing and go to your
husband I mean you're in a relationship
you're in a marriage for a reason to
share these things to support and uplift
each other and help each other and you
need to let your husband know what is
going on in your mind if you aren't
happy with things and also the husband
with the wife because if you go to that
other person to vent it just turns into
gossip later and it creates a really bad
and sour relationship between your
husband then and that other person that
you've entered with you know so it's
really important don't share your
personal stuff with other people and
make them part of the issue there are
things that should stay in marriage
Nikita and I we have a rule you know
sometimes when we have a disagreement
we never act in the flesh right we tell
ourselves don't act in a flesh and when
you're a little bit filled that you're a
bit heated go
go to scripture find out what the Bible
says come back amen solve the problem
Nikita thinks this I think this okay but
what does the Bible say what is the
truth
um
so let's continue here therefore what
God has joined together no person is to
separate
marriage isn't just a promise between a
husband and a wife it's a promise to God
too many people divorced too easily
today because they are not willing to
sacrifice the self-life and work hard
at marriage
a promise to remain with your spouse for
the rest of your life
it's a promise that takes quite a bit of
work to fulfill
it's not easy
Falling in Love is Easy
it's very easy staying in love is a
challenge for most people
the key
listen closely because this is the key
that unlocks a good marriage the key to
a successful marriage lies in having
agape love at all times through the
spirit
I cannot stress this enough
say it again say it again
all right the key to a successful
marriage lies in having agape love
at all times through this Spirit yes if
you if you always put God first you will
have an amazing marriage amen
and I'm gonna ask you to dig deep at the
end of every daily devotion I'll ask you
to do some self-reflection in Ephesians
5 23 Paul said for the husband is the
head of the wife as Christ also is the
head of the church if a husband takes
this responsibility seriously and leads
in a christ-like way
his wife and children will gladly follow
him if you treat your wife like a queen
she will treat you like a king
if you walk
like Jesus because that's our aim right
as reborn Christians to follow in the
footsteps of Jesus to be like him
then it will be easy for your wife to
follow you because all you're doing is
just following what God's word says and
then she needs to listen to you but if
you say certain things that is outside
of God's word
she doesn't need to listen to you so
you're not the boss you're the leader
that leads gently the way that Christ
leads the church amen
ask yourself the following questions and
answer them truthfully are you ready for
this if you want to you guys can answer
there in the live chat or in the comment
section
first question Nikita maybe you wanna
yeah sure read
question
do you lead your wife in a loving and
gentle manner like Christ leads the
church
we can't answer this for you
you need to answer this and question two
what does a husband's sacrificial love
look like in a healthy marriage
I wonder these questions are very deep
and so you shouldn't just brush it off
and quickly answer it you you need to
think about it and be truthful with
yourself it doesn't if if you are
truthful and If you deny some of the
truth that you know is is fact of how
you treat your wife or how you are in
your marriage then
it you are going to be worse off if if
you lie to yourself and if you're not
honest because you need to truthfully
honest yourself to know where the place
is in your personality are or in in the
issues are that you need to work on
right right
and um I just want to say that this is
very important for a lot of men to
understand you know the role of a
husband
we talked about the role of a wife as
well on the LM Christian lifestyle and
you know when I talk about these things
I see children
and I feel my heart goes out to a lot of
kids
you know who are being abandoned by a
father in South Africa we have a lot of
fatherless homes
be a man man up I have the merch on
today man up you can get this merch in
the video description if you if you like
it but you need to man up yep you need
to act in the spirit be like Christ take
your responsibility as a husband as a
father seriously yeah
and for I know that they there's a
certain amount of
um a certain percentage of women that
also follow DL and men's lifestyle that
we've seen on the demographics so around
10 15 thank you by the way thank you
um and for those women that are
specifically watching or even
um husbands if you are watching now and
and you want to maybe call your wife and
tell them to listen to the section
whilst it is very important like Daniel
said we also discussed the role of the
wife in the Christian lifestyle video if
you want to go over and have a look at
that but it is important that the wife
also knows these things and as the
husband loves the wife the wife needs to
be respectful and kind and gentle and
caring also to her husband back because
it's it's easy to say yes the husband
needs to be the action to get the proper
and correct reaction from his wife and
he needs to be the leader but then again
if you aren't the correct support system
and and the you know
like a proper Christian support system
for your husband it's also not going to
work so it's it's not a I've heard
people say a relationship or marriage is
50 50. no that's not it it's actually
hundred hundred you need to put in all
your effort and all your your strength
that you can into your marriage and the
day that you feel like you can only give
80 that's when the other person
compromises and does 120. man I've got
an amazing wife right
I make a lot of mistakes too but that's
why I can share my experience and my
advice
so so
um I think we should move over
um before we tell you guys about the
competition
let's take a look at a few questions
here do you guys have any questions
about the book and I just want to share
this a little bit right you can you can
buy different books on different topics
but this book deals with those different
topics 90 days 90 daily devotionals that
you can do and it doesn't take long you
see how we work through this very quick
and um yeah I would love to support on
this book and I just want to thank you
guys thank you for the support on my
channel for the I mean we're almost 1
million that's that's amazing what God
has been doing I've seen the kids
already looking at sorry I'm looking at
the comments top chat here okay yeah on
that note thank you so much for the
support everybody just just a quick side
note on that we really appreciate it
all right so we do have a little bit of
a delay here with the Wi-Fi but let's
see uh Dylan says can't wait to get the
book it should be coming today God bless
yeah it is coming today it is out you
can get it right now in America Canada
get in the stores you can also uh Nikita
shared at the beginning of this video
you can go to bold Pursuit book.com
you'll see all the links there you can
get it on Amazon there's a few places
you can get it it's going to come out a
little bit later uh at different
countries like South Africa's will be a
little bit later this year like places
like com books exclusive books
um but it doesn't matter where you live
you can get the ebook and
that I've done a voice over so that will
definitely help for those of you who
like cycling yeah jogging driving far
and just listen to me reading the book
any more questions about the book guys
we we are going to give a few more
seconds for the questions to come
through if you have questions that you
want to ask us specifically with regards
to the book
um what are some of the other questions
on the Christian Lifestyle Channel that
we got I just want to give a quick while
you think uh shout out to Kevin
Hawthorne
um from Florida man thank you so much I
see you in the premieres in the live
chat a lot and I just want to thank you
for your support God bless you and your
family yes thank you so much all right
so one of the other questions that I ask
what is the reason for the name bold
Pursuit
hmm well yeah we talked about that a
little bit at the beginning of the video
but if you just joined bold Pursuit is
about truly pursuing Jesus Christ no
matter the cost you know the disciples
followed Jesus
and what they had what a lot of people
don't have today is they came to the
point of complete surrender
where God is first above everything else
in our lives
so bold Pursuit is really about pursuing
Jesus Christ there's nothing more
important than that a lot of people
pursue alcohol gambling you know playing
games there are different things that
people try to find
that peace you know unconditional peace
that surpasses all understanding but you
can only find that in Jesus
yeah so um let's look at some of the
questions here someone else asked what
is agape
Agape I struggle with that one agape
love is the love that God has for you
unconditional he loved you while you
were still a sinner
he doesn't love your sin but he loves
you unconditionally
and that's the same kind of love that we
have received from God when we became
reborn Christians we received his spirit
in us and that also gives us the ability
to love other people through his love
unconditional love it means that it
doesn't matter what Nikita does if she
screams at me I'm not gonna not love her
anymore I'm gonna love her
so that's unconditional love ero's love
is that kind of love that's more
romantic right but between a husband and
a wife but Eros Love sometimes will come
and go because you will have
disagreements marriage is hard work but
it is the agape love that will carry you
through until the end yeah and there's
another good question from Janine what
other topics are you going to be
covering in your book Daniel there's a
few topics like how yeah how to fight
through the spirit and not the flesh
um how to come to the point of complete
surrender there's a few things like the
gift of the spirit there's a few things
it will really help you to to boost your
spiritual growth in Christ yes and I
just want to mention for the ladies on
the channel and husbands even you guys
can buy it for your wives this is I know
the book is specifically targeted admin
but it's a really really really good
book I read it and I can honestly say
that it is very insightful for women too
because obviously like this section it
will help you to understand for example
um the role of the husband also
um and it is just something that you can
honestly use in your own life you know
advice and knowledge and how to navigate
your relationship and grow in your
relationship with God yeah so it's good
for women too I just want to say to
Janine as well when you look at the the
back of the the book is a few things
here as well that you can
experience while you explore the book
how to worship God in spirit and in
truth
what it means to engage in spiritual
battle Watson is and isn't and why it
matters
where to find hope when you're feeling
hopeless
practical ways to overcome destructive
habits and addictions oh this is so
important a lot of men are struggling
with pornography today we get a lot of
emails yeah so this will help and how to
make Bible study and prayer an
integrated part of your life but at the
end of it after reading this book my
prayer is that you would come to the
point of complete surrender
because that changes everything yeah if
you don't know what that means you can
you can have a look on the alarm
Christian lifestyle where I shared
videos on complete surrender yeah you
want to share something yeah now I just
want to say it is the moment for the
competition
[Music]
exciting exciting times like I said
before we are giving away 10 free copies
of the book bold Pursuits now how can
you enter this competition you need to
listen carefully and unfortunately this
is only for USA residents and Canadian
residents only USA and Canada because
that's where the book is available in
hard copy right now the question that we
want the answer to Is
oh just so you know
you need to be fast right because
there's a lot of people
send it to me on Twitter DM me at Daniel
L Moritz my new Twitter page or what
they call it X today don't they I've got
no idea so send it to me uh when you
know the answer okay are you ready yes
and the question is
what is the law Bible verse that Daniel
quoted on last week's dlm Christian
Lifestyles video so you need to go to
his other channel dlm Christian
lifestyle and watch the last video which
is called follow Jesus no matter the
cost ball Pursuit Bible study we'll put
the link in the video description for
you guys
so the question is again I'm going to
repeat what is the last Bible verse that
Daniel quoted on last week's dlm
Christian lifestyle video remember the
first 10 correct answers get the book
yes the dlm the DMS Daniel on his
Twitter account Daniel Al maritz but
we'll also put that in the video
description I'll send it to you and that
video is called follow Jesus no matter
the cost yeah so important bold Pursuit
Bible study yes all right let's just
have a look here is there any last
questions about the book
uh let's see here I see Matthew question
mark Janine
Marcus aurelis thanks for the ESV
recommendations you carry and I got a
copy nice thank you Sandra uh yes I
agree with you said about book is good
for women too great Crystal
nakuru uh
uh okay that's about someone else Janine
Fosters up good luck us and Canadians
all right okay looks like there's not a
lot of questions anymore I just want to
thank you guys for all the support
please share the video to your husband
your father your uncles your
grandfathers your son we need more
spiritual spiritual men who are not
afraid who are bold who want to follow
Jesus Christ no matter the cost like
David you can come to that point and say
Father Here I Am check out everything
that is not right
and they need to pursue Jesus Christ no
matter the cost there's nothing more
important than that in this short
temporary world I mean
so guys thank you for joining and
remember
God loves you and we love you too we
love you too bye guys
now I just need to get to Exodus button
see we're not used to screaming where is
it where is it